[Música]
obrigado é todo muito feliz de estar
participando há aqui do evento ainda
mais que eu vou poder compartilhar com
vocês
uma das questões que me perseguiram boa
parte da minha vida porque alguns países
são ricos e outros países são pobres
porque o brasil ainda não deu certo
então eu recorri a diversos ramos do
conhecimento teorias econômicas e cair
no conceito cunhado por filósofo nassim
taleb chamado ante frágil a maioria de
vocês nunca ouviu falar do conceito
diante frágil que fique registrado num
futuro muito breve esse conceito vai ser
o mais difundido vocês vão cansar de
ouvir falar de nassim taleb e do
conceito do anti frágil para explicar o
conceito doente e frágil da forma mais
simples e direta possível vamos pensar o
que é o frágil pensa num objeto com uma
taça de vidro lá se tiver qualquer
desordem volatilidade perturbação essa
taxa tende a quebrar
ela é frágil já se perguntassem para as
pessoas com que o oposto do frágil richa
aí vem na cabeça aquele conceito que é
super difundido robusto resiliente não o
robusto e resiliente ele simplesmente
sobreviver e suporta os choques
então ele é neutro o anti frágil não ele
se beneficia do caos das variações de
todos os membros da família da desordem
inclusive o fator tempo
então imagina um pacotinho se fosse
antes frágil ao invés de está escrito lá
no correio frágil cuidado que pode
quebrar o que tem dentro
ele faz uma viagem longa
de carga é chacoalhado bate na hora que
ele chega ele chega mais forte ele se
beneficia e esse conceito durante frágil
e pode ser aplicado em todas as áreas
todas hoje eu vou mostrar pra vocês uma
aplicação na economia países que são
frágeis e países que são anti frizz ou
seja países que de repente parece que
está tudo indo bem
de repente vem um colapso econômico e
países que não importa a incerteza não
importa a crise eles se fortalecem ficam
cada vez mais fortes ea gente vai
entender o porquê disso o anti frágil eo
frágil ele aparece em sistemas complexos
que sistema complexo é tudo aquilo que
tem muitas partes conectadas sofrendo
interações competindo com perãodo entre
si aquela bagunça que você perde a noção
de causa e efeito você não consegue
saber o que está causando o que é o
mundo real ele é complexo apesar de você
ter vários especialistas e ramos do
conhecimento querendo tratar o mundo
bonitinho linear modelinhos cá querendo
fazer previsões não ele é complexo e
está se tornando cada vez mais complexo
pela ação humana mais etapas mais
procedimento e por isso que se a gente
reparar dos tempos pra cá
quantas crises uma colada na outra no
mundo quanto os acontecimentos tivemos
aí recentemente e ontem é um super
ataque hacker
então o mundo muito conectado cada vez
mais complexo então eu vou mostrar pra
vocês um manual para a gente entender o
que torna uma economia frágil e o que
torna uma economia ante frágil porque a
gente tem que discutir principalmente
nesse momento nosso país tudo o que a
gente vem passando a gente tem que
voltar a ter a ambição de querer chegar
a um patamar maior chega só de reclamar
no brasil é assim não tem um caminho ea
gente vai ver como antes disso eu quero
mostrar pra vocês que essa imagem
ela resume como a maioria dos
economistas explicam a economia e uma
minoria explica economias e vi aí você
tem um gato dentro de uma máquina de
lavar roupas
o a maioria dos economistas tratam a
economia como se fosse uma máquina de
lavar roupa ou seja um sistema tão
complexo que eles conhecem as
engrenagens que tudo é bonitinho linear
previsível mas não o mundo real a
economia real ela se parece muito mais
com gato que é um sistema complexo então
essa é uma distinção muito importante do
não complexo do complexo tem que parar
de tratar a economia como se fosse algo
mecânico é algo natural a gente tem que
voltar às raízes da natureza vocês vão
ver a 1 dentro dos itens que eu separei
o que fragiliza uma economia ou seja o
que torna essa economia mais vulnerável
a qualquer tipo de incerteza ou
atividade variações qualquer coisa que
saia do script que dê errado essa
economia e ela já pode entrar em colapso
primeiro ponto centralização esse
conceito você pode aplicar tanto pra
país empresa decisões
olha só isso aqui é um sistema de redes
e sistemas de redes é o coração do
sistema complexo então visualmente a
gente vai entender por que que a
centralização é frágil e pode ler
milhões de livros teorias argumenta olha
que fácil você tem aí as conexões do
primeira figura
quanto maior a bolinha quer dizer que
tem mais conexões dela
olha só um sistema extremamente
centralizado tem um grande rabino meio e
tudo conectado a ele
aí eu pergunto esse rap ele comete um
erro gravíssimo ele espalha ou não para
todos os outros
imediatamente agora pior ainda esse
grande rabi sofre um ataque ea gente
tira ele que acontece com esse sistema
se parte
a rixa de vamos montar agora um negócio
é bonito mas descentralizar olha lá tem
os ramos ali mas tem um hub central
também
para ele o que acontece com a rede se
parte agora um sistema verdadeiramente
descentralizado sentir os principais
ramos a rede continua existindo então um
todo a economia que tem por exemplo um
governo central um governo federal um
parlamento europeu tomando as decisões
por diversas outras regiões é frágil a
descentralização é o caminho você pensar
em termos locais cuidar primeiro do seu
bairro na sua cidade
imagina uma pessoa lhe distante tomando
todas as decisões e espalhando erros ou
se ela tiver algum problema ela
comprometendo toda a rede então toda
centralização é frágil seja em países
seja empresa intervencionismo ingênua
que é o que é o ser humano achar que
hoje em dia é moderno demais e pegar a
estatística de tudo que é coisa aí eu
tenho dados big data e aí ele fica o que
tentado a querer consertar tudo aquilo
que ele acha que está errado e aí acaba
provocando que na medicina chamado de
iatrogenia que que a iatrogenia é quando
o tratamento provoca um mal muito maior
do que a própria doença então o efeito
colateral do tratamento acaba sendo
muito pior do que a doença então o
interventor ingênua e acha que ele tem
que mexer em tudo e como é um sistema
complexo mundo real que a gente não tem
noção de causa e efeito e ele começa a
fazer a maior bagunça um exemplo pra
vocês históricos muito interessante é a
história de ronchi enron que o sam
monkhouse white que comandava a aaron
quando ela ainda não era próspera
sabe qual foi a atitude dele ele mandou
fechar os institutos de estatística que
ele falou se não tiver dados o reino
unido da grã-bretanha não vai mexer aqui
então não vão querer ficar propondo uma
política a uma política bem como não tem
dado então deixa rolar deixa aí no
natural então cuidado com isso tem
muitos ruídos no mundo de hoje foquem
mais em sinais concretos então
interventor engenheiro fragiliza aquela
história de havana
os intervir em tudo que era baixar o
preço disso quer aquilo quero impedir
que a empresa a empresa tal faça isso
isso sempre dá errado decisões que dão
certo
as que vêm de baixo pra cima das pessoas
as que dão errado as que vêm de cima pra
baixo dívidas dívida é sempre uma
escravidão e para o país porque quando
você está endividado você país pessoa ou
empresa
você perdeu a sua margem de manobra você
está na mão dos outros qualquer
imprevisto que você tiver você está
condenado você todo o seu plano tem que
dar certo caso contrário só você pensa
tatuado indivíduo uma pessoa uma empresa
um país
ele tem algum tipo de escolha ou ele tem
que acabou de ser escolhido então
dívidas sempre fragiliza esse negócio de
dívida boa dívida ruim o cara fala aí
será enxuta e lico que toda a dívida é
frágil produzir castanhas de caju chips
de computador soja o carros bananas ou
computadores faz diferença
toda diferença um país é rico pra você
ver se é rico é aquilo que todos os
habitantes juntos de forma coletiva são
capazes de produzir países ricos
produzem produtos e serviços de alto
valor agregado produtos de alta
complexidade países que só produzem
recursos naturais
o tipo de sociedade que emerge disso é
muito ruim é nefasto mais pra frente a
gente vai ver porque quando você parte
para produzir produtos e serviços de
alto valor agregado emerge um outro tipo
de sociedade um outro tipo de
produtividade tem outro tipos de
exigências instituições
então assim um país que está focado só
nesses produtos
ele é frágil além disso tem um
economista que criou uma teoria tav
ricardo vantagens culpa comparativas e
fala ah não você é bom em produzir
banana produzidas ou banana e com o
dinheiro que você vê na banana você
compra de outros produtos mas de maior
valor agregado
só tem um problema
ricardo com o que é o problema e se o
preço da banana desaba e se ninguém mais
no mundo quer comer banana
tá vendo você está totalmente focado é
igual àquela empresa que tem um grande
cliente eo resto organizado se aquele
cliente vai embora da empresa que
aconteceu
a empresa a receita da empresa desaba de
repente falta de pele em risco isso que
entreguei me quer dizer o que você tem
muitas pessoas nos países das economias
frágeis tomando decisões sem o deles na
reta sem a pele deles em risco se dá
errado aquilo ele não tem nenhuma
desvantagem nenhuma e não responde por
aquilo isso vale também para empresas e
setores protegidos e até profissionais
que às vezes prega uma coisa e você vai
ver na vida real do cara ele não aplicar
aquilo a pele dele não tem risco essa
imagem é o rei é alexandre o grande
porque eu fiz questão de colocar ele
queria declarar guerra ele queria ser um
grande conquistador mas ele era o
primeiro a falar na linha de frente da
batalha ou seja ele tomava decisões mas
a pele dele estava em risco isso é um
diferencial brutal uma sociedade que
todo mundo está com a pele risco que se
responsabiliza pelas suas ações
as pessoas tomam outro tipo de acções
agora uma sociedade que você não importa
o que você decida não é você que vai
dançar o ônus não vai vir pra você a
desvantagem eu só poderia dar certo a
vantagem ao richard aí dá cara legal a
idéia errado você se ferre eu não eu
falar é a vida é assim
pele em risco já na economia antes
frágil ou seja uma economia que não
existe uma economia perfeita no mundo um
país assim se tem graus de anti
fragilidade uns mais outros menos como
gal de fragilidade também como por
exemplo o brasil passou um tempo atrás e
vi que em 2010 o pib cresceu 7% o
indicador econômico todo mundo acompanha
o pib está crescendo
só que cresceu com fragilidade e agora
todo mundo está sentindo na pele a conta
então cuidado também com indicadores
econômicos têm que ver se você está
acumulando ou removendo as fragilidades
da economia sente frágil a primeira
característica é essa descentralizadas
o melhor exemplo político que vocês
podem ter é a suíça
quem é o presidente da suíça a maioria
nem vai saber porquê porque lá muda todo
ano você tem uma democracia direta
lá valoriza a localidade cada suíço pode
opinar ali daquela região que a próxima
dele do dia a dia ele pode cobrar o cara
que está tomando a ação o cara não tá
longe e ele não tem nem como cobrar é o
dia a dia é a pele em risco então se
vocês querem que pesquisar um sistema
político sensacional pesquisa como
funciona os cantões aí da suíça outro
exemplo de descentralização alemanha
alemanha a produção dela é muito
descentralizado eles priorizam muito
empresas que têm de 100 a 200
funcionários e principalmente as
economias locais e eles vão interligando
todo o país a vender um formando aquela
rede que a gente viu mais
descentralizadas eficiência da fia
negativa
isso é um conceito mais importante que
tem ao invés de você ser o interventor
em gene que ele ficar acrescentando
coisas aquela economia primeiro foque em
remover as fragilidades e isso vale para
a vida também
ao invés de querer acrescentar qual tem
que fazer tem o carlos tem que primeiro
mapear as suas fragilidades e removê las
remova fragilidade é o caminho natural
para você alcançar a amt fragilidade ou
seja se beneficiar do caos se beneficiar
da aleatoriedade se beneficiar da
incerteza estrutura produtiva
diversificado da economia sant frases
produzem de tudo principalmente produtos
e serviços de alto valor agregado e para
isso os físicos que estão estudando as
redes
o cesar hidalgo eo barabási olha que
legal eles descobriram que o ser humano
e as empresas têm um limite de
capacidade de armazenamento de
informações e pra você fabricar produtos
complexos passa desse limite então por
exemplo uma persona pensão byte
então por exemplo a fabricar um avião se
precisaria de 15 perceber ou seja que
estão mostrando que o pai
esqueci da economia que se torna se
frágil é aquela que as pessoas e
empresas conseguem formar alianças
ninguém vai sozinho tanto que eles
formam um sistema produtivo e eficiente
coletivo quer ver o maior exemplo disso
como é que explica que o tal do
trabalhador brasileiro que é ineficiente
em produtivo se você remove esse cara
daqui insere ele em sistemas coletivos
produtivos como alemanha japão só deve
ser inserido lá passa o tempo algumas
semanas o cara já está produzindo igual
um alemão igual japonês porque a chave
de tudo produtividade é uma questão
coletiva e não individual
esse é o pulo do gato e uma estrutura
produtiva de produtos e serviços
complexos a industrialização se tem
diversas etapas que são necessárias se
desenvolve uma indústria de serviços
complexos está aí a revolução 4.0 que
vai ser máquina conversando com máquina
da fábrica ou seja cria os melhores
postos de trabalho àqueles que vão pagar
altos salários e não aqueles que vão
desaparecer
então o brasil enquanto ele for focada
em um país de commodities
ele está condenado ele tem que partir
para diversifica a produção parte para
industrialização e formar um sistema
coletivo eficiente melhorando a
infraestrutura porque melhora a
infraestrutura é importante que você
está facilitando as conexões entre as
redes é isso a gente se conectar e o
brasileiro ganhar consciência que ele
tem que trabalhar em equipe
nenhum país se torna se frágil
componentes individuais brilhantes se
torna se frágil com uma mente coletiva
brilhante pouca dependência externa e
redundância ou seja tem um nível de
endividamento baixo e redundante olha o
relógio aí se falha no meio os outros
continuam funcionando isso é um
princípio da natureza a natureza se
prepara para aquilo que não aconteceu
por isso se você gosta de olhar o
passado e séries históricas para tomar
essa decisão esqueça porque vai
acontecer aquilo que não está na
a história ea natureza vem se preparando
para isso por isso que a natureza está
aí até hoje expostos periodicamente os
agentes estressores quer dizer o quê
livre concorrência incentivo à
competição então tem que competir tem
que sentir sempre fora da zona de
conforto chega país frágil é aquele que
protege setores é o pai é o país dos
coitadinhos durante frágil não todo
mundo ali disputando mas e incentivando
o erro mas agora vocês vão ver como é o
sistema de centralizado o seu se
propagam não eles servem de aprendizado
você aprende já que não comprometeu o
sistema agora o sistema frágil
centralizado aconteceu qualquer erro é o
tipo de erro que não pode acontecer
porque ele fragmentada toda a rede é o
erro que leva à extinção e por isso
para finalizar uma frase que foi dita
num seriado aí que está fazendo muito
sucesso até perguntaram para taleb se
ele fez essa frase e ele disse não me
lembro mas está totalmente aprovada
então eu compartilho com vocês bicam
antifraude war da em português se torne
ante frágil ou morra muito obrigado
[Aplausos]